oui c'est toute la partie de production
qui a été détruite ravagé par cet
incendie qui s'est déclaré aux alentours
de 13h45 à l'intérieur clairement il ne
reste plus rien et puis ce qui inquiète
particulièrement la cinquantaine de
pompiers sur place c'est le vent qui
rabat cette épaisse colonne de fumée et
les flammes en direction de l'autre
partie la partie administrative qui a
été un peu moins touchée par cet
incendie
et c'est donc ça que tentent de
maîtriser les pompiers alors sur place
aucune victime n'est à déplorer car tous
les employés ont pu être évacués ceux
qui travaillaient sur place
et puis c'est une entreprise assez
symbolique pour la région fabrice
gillotte c'est un chocolatier meilleur
ouvrier de france est donc très
symbolique pour notre région et donc à
l'arrêt aujourd'hui